I want total immersion
while I'm here in Berlin,
so I've asked my good friend
Flula Borg to teach me
(audience cheering)
all things Berlin, German, so that,
no you don't want to?
This is my, when I'm enthusiastic,
I just, it's a shaking of all the energies
inside my head to spread it even.
So that was you saying yes?
Okay, just say yes.
Yes.
Okay, Flula is going to help me learn
all about Berlin, the customs, the people,
and I thought it'd be nice
if we also could eat at the same time.
So let's just go crazy
and order some stuff.
I love it, do you like hot and cold?
Do you like both of the temperatures?
Uh, yes, I love both
of the temperatures.
(speaks foreign language)
Perfect.
This is the slaughter plate.
This is just everything?
Oh, yes, the whole kit and caboodle.
And it's just a bunch of animals
were in a bus and it blew up.
Yeah.
(audience laughs)
Yes, perfect.
We'll get a schnitzel as well.
What is schnitzel?
Exactly, let us look at it.
It's pounded pork with
a nice skin of crumbs.
Oh, great, terrific.
You will love it, you will
want to roll around in it.
Well, I, no.
[Flula] Look at that.
That is so much beer.
It's an exchange rate,
this is one German beer
which equals 45 Bud Lights.
Okay, so what do I do, you just?
Yeah, prost.
Prost, we must toast.
Always with the eyes.
You cannot look at like a plant.
So it would be very rude if I was
like prost, that would be bad.
I would not drink with you.
I'd pour this into my
testicles, I would not drink it.
When do we stop looking at each other?
We don't.
And is there a kiss at some point?
We may smooch it, it is an option.
Prost, where are you from?
Vietnam.
You're from Vietnam?
Prost!
Here comes the slaughter.
Slaughter platter.
(audience laughs)
Keep looking.
Don't fear it.
Sexually this town feels very
uninhibited like they love the sex.
They love the freedom of it, is that true?
Why are we hiding it?
Do you know?
It's like if you are having
a nice comic book collection,
would you hide Amazing
Spiderman number eight?
(audience laughs)
No.
No you would put it on the wall
and show all of your neighbors.
Okay.
Do you need to know some phrases?
I can teach you some happy phrases.
Teach me some phrases.
If you like something,
it's very delicious you say.
(speaks foreign language)
Which means I could sit in it.
The image is I would
make a tub of this food
and then I would bathe inside it.
(audience laughs)
(speaks foreign language)
Which means you probably do not have
all of the cups inside your cupboard.
(audience laughs)
Means you are cuckoo.
Oh you're cuckoo.
(audience laughs)
You don't have all the
cups inside your cupboard?
You have an incomplete cupboard.
(audience laughs)
[Conan] Can you teach
me any drinking songs?
Yeah, there's one called,
“One more will fit inside you.”
One more will fit inside you?
Yeah.
(audience laughs)
Beer.
Yeah.
Well yes beer.
(singing in foreign language)
(laughing)